Géraldine maillet Jordan bah non
franchement le salaire
je crois que c'est une des plus plus
payés sur le sur le plateau
[Rires]
c'est combien à peu près par mois il
faudrait que je demande à la gérance de
ma société donc je vous dirai la
prochaine fois
que moins que Mathieu Delormeau moins
que Benjamin Castaldi moins que Bernard
Montiel
ça doit être autour de ça oui
il est fort
Raymond
combien de litres de diesel
[Rires]
comment les enfants la mère de tes
enfants
Stéphanie fait combien de temps vous
êtes ensemble je les connais à la
maternelle est-ce que tu as déjà fait un
écart c'est un [__]
ça suffit
[Rires]
qui pourrait être tartiner le feu
[Applaudissements]
on peut dire ça
non mais c'est vrai je dirais que
celle-ci celle qui a l'air le plus tenté
par la chose parce qu'elle a déjà
embrassé des filles et tout ça sur le
plateau c'est Géraldine
j'ai déglingué mercredi
[Rires]
attend
est-ce que tu connais la date de ton
départ de Touche pas à mon poste
c'est une bonne question et il est
possible que oui
[Rires]
je m'en fous totalement
parce que si les peaux courants et que
lui au courant
[Rires]
c'est vrai l'équipe parce que comme vous
êtes toutes nouvelles
ils sont tous sympas
[Rires]
ok vas-y Jean-Marie Bigard ça va
Jean-Marie et toi
je t'ai connu à l'époque où je buvais
encore
c'est fini mais il y a beaucoup de gens
qui ont repris l'alcool après avoir vu
Jordan
j'ai l'impression tu as changé depuis
mon poste c'est vrai sincèrement maigri
tu bois plus bien sûr bien sûr j'ai
toujours le petit prix
je vois juste savoir ce que ça a changé
dans ta vie le fait que Cyril te mette
sur le plateau et que tu sois là tous
les soirs juste qu'est-ce que ça a fait
qu'est-ce que ça t'a changé et si tu
n'étais pas là qu'est-ce que tu serais
selon toi devenir j'étais un petit peu
parti pour disparaître tranquillement tu
vois disparaître comme un vieux grognon
qui ouvre tout le temps sa gueule à
temps et à travers et là tout à coup je
renais de mes centres mes cendres grâce
à Cyril et je lui j'ai une éternelle
reconnaissance pour pour lui quoi c'est
bon Jean-Marie
déjà c'est un talent exceptionnel et
c'est pour ça que tu es là avant tout je
te le dis et aussi tu es et tu es
vraiment mon ami pour toujours et tu le
sais et on a eu on a traversé des choses
ensemble et on est toujours ensemble et
il y a pas de il y aura jamais
tu tiens la main à ceux qui sont en bas
pardon mais faut se souvenir merci tu
cherches quoi
[Rires]
va falloir peut-être les faire remonter
un peu
alors à Valérie Valérie pourquoi tu
m'aimais pas quand j'étais ton élève à
l'école parce que je trouvais que tu
étais une caricature et que tu fais
jouer à l'animateur dis pas toi-même tu
te cacher derrière quelque chose
ça je voulais que tu enlèves non mais
parce que justement je trouvais que tu
avais un talent et que tu te cachais
derrière des choses parce que tu avais
peur de d'être de montrer qui tu étais
et donc je voulais que tu enlèves tous
les hôpitaux pour être le vrai et pas
un faux Jordan qui joue
Jordan maintenant c'est encore encore
quelques scories mais tu peux tu
progresses bien très bien allez Mathieu
alors Mathieu le problème c'est qu'il
m'a dit 4 fois de mauvaise question
alors tu poses des questions que tu veux
allez vas-y même à moi non mais arrête
mais il est en train de me faire tomber
allez dépêche-toi tu nous as pas épargné
dépêche-toi dépêche-toi allez vas-y
Jordan est-ce que tu as déjà eu une
aventure avec une personne autour de ce
plateau non ben je te dis tout de suite
non non non non non même aucun
chroniqueur
mais je me souviens de rien
quand j'étais bourré non non je regarde
les garçons sont pas à mon goût les
filles sont très belles tu sais quoi en
ce moment il a un petit crush sur
Delphine Wespiser
j'ai assez de problèmes comme ça
oublie-moi dans cette école
est-ce que ça se vend oui alors vas-y
alors allez vas-y allez Jordan Jordan
allez Jordan qu'est-ce qui se cache
vraiment derrière toi Guillaume parce
que j'arrive pas à savoir c'est des gens
très sympa
tu peux enlever les lunettes pour voir
déjà ouais pourquoi tu mets toujours des
lunettes
à ma quéquette
en ce moment c'est pas de moi c'est ça
tient bien ouais c'est une très belle
personne que j'ai rencontré
un terminal non je vais rencontrer sur
les réseaux sociaux et ça se passe bien
ça fait on se voit depuis six mois à peu
près c'est bon vous êtes super discret
ouais parce qu'une fois tu as même cru
que je te filmais avec elle je te
rappelle de ça et il a très mal pris
alors que j'ai jamais voulu donner son
identité mais pourquoi tu as autant peur
de ça c'est parce que tu as peur qu'elle
te pas parce que c'est une personne que
certaines personnes connaissent et j'ai
pas envie de d'accord mais parce que la
notoriété pour aller faire du mal au
couple de quoi la notoriété pourrait
faire du mal au couple non c'est une
personne que des gens connaissent autour
de ce plateau donc c'est on a regardé il
m'a regardé
et elle a vraiment changé ta vie avant
tu étais un peu plus liberté entre
guillemets
quelque chose à lui dire tu lui dirais
quoi en deux mots bonjour
parce que moi
[Applaudissements]
bisous
Lopez il m'a dit plein de belles choses
transparence transparence la première
question c'est combien vous gagnez tout
le monde veut savoir
tout le monde
c'est quoi la deuxième question c'est
est-ce que vous êtes en couple non il y
en a trois en fait vas-y alors
dépêche-toi la première c'est combien ce
que vous gagnez par mois je ne sais pas
impossible je suis producteur de
l'émission donc je sais pas
je sais plus voilà
[Rires]
et tout le monde les locaux oui mais
attendez de trouver son salaire de
sauver ton boulot
ce serait content
je ne sais pas est-ce qu'il y a un
moment où vraiment vous êtes fait peur
vous avez vu un un montant où vous êtes
dit je pensais jamais gagner
le plus beau cadeau que vous avez fait
votre fils mon fils Ben un immeuble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'amour d'un père non non je lui ai
offert un vélo très beau vélo
c'était pour une bonne cause en plus
c'était pour la voilà c'est pour le la
fondation du PSG c'est lors d'une vente
aux enchères et il m'a coûté beaucoup
d'argent c'est combien beaucoup d'argent
90.000 euros
le vélo de vélo
pour l'association
la deuxième question c'est est-ce que
vous êtes en couple et si oui avec qui
déjà je vais vous arrêter direct je ne
suis pas en couple je suis célibataire
d'accord donc célibataire célibataire
[Rires]
je suis célibataire voilà là c'est tu
peux vérifier voilà c'est une personne
ici qui pouvait vous plaire autour du
plateau en femme il y a personne ce
serait là ce soir non
ça aurait pu arriver mais pas là ça
aurait pu arriver avec une autre
chroniqueuse
est-ce que vous êtes bisexuel non pas du
tout
tu ne boufferas jamais le cul
content toi de faire ton émission le
matin et qu'il passera très bien
d'accord très bien parce que tu l'as tu
est-ce que ça sous-entend pardon mais tu
dois donc un autre pourrait faire
tourner à l'école samedi
voilà je crois qu'on a fait le tour
et je note que franchement vous avez
répondu honnêtement alors
sur célibataire oui euh combien je gagne
par mois je te dis ici compliqué je l'ai
mais c'est est-ce que c'est compliqué
d'être en couple avec vous Cyril est-ce
que non c'est souvent compliqué d'être
en couple avec une personnalité ce
qu'elle a noté il y a pas que je regarde
les autres sont en couple aussi ah c'est
pour ça oui mais c'est plutôt des coupes
frivole tous ces gens là